au fait la belle deux étoiles remis ce
soir au foyer club handisport à trophées
initiée depuis plusieurs années par la
fédération française handisport qui
permet de distinguer des clubs qui ont
su développer la pratique du sport
auprès d'adhérents porteurs de handicap
annabelle qui continue une à trois
étoiles et donc avec ses deux étoiles le
foia le club est le premier club
handisport de la caraïbe à obtenir cette
distinction
c'est pour moi un grand honneur de nous
avons permis des étoiles et sur le
département nous nous permettrons de de
bouger et de de grandir en plus ici le
fruit de travail de beaucoup de jeunes
sportifs qui se donnent tous les jours
dit se motive au quotidien qui porte en
compétition qui viennent avec des
trophées qui est le fruit de
l'encadrement jeu connaissant nos
encadrement ici nous aurons pas plus
recevoir